[Musique]
capturé un instant un mouvement 26 chez
sont rassemblés autour de la danse
principalement dan ramène s'est attaché
à plusieurs compagnies en résidence ou
en représentation avec la mission danse
de saint quentin en yvelines
l'idée c'est de croiser aussi les
artistes que nous programmons et puis
les rencontres se font ne se font pas et
là ça c'est fait il se trouve que notre
partenariat avec la mission danse ça a
été de le faire que ils puissent
rencontrer des chorégraphes donc il a
assisté à il a rencontré plusieurs
chorégraphies la cité à plusieurs
spectacles avec ses photographies d'al
ram n entrent au coeur du geste et de
l'impression qu'il laisse son exposition
est le résultat d'une rencontre avec les
équipes de la commanderie
c'était une carte blanche donc ça fait
un an qu'il y travaille et je ne pouvais
pas préjuger du résultat plastique
puisqu'il s'agissait d' expérimenter
corps et mouvements donc ça pouvait être
corps mouvement encore en mouvement
encore c'est lui qui a choisi comme il a
expérimenté plusieurs choses il ya des
choses qui sont floues et des choses qui
sont extrêmement précises extrêmement
nettes et ça donne un ensemble hyper
cohérent et c'est une partie de la
réponse à la question aux questions
qu'il s'est posé d'hui
avec ces clichés le temps semble
suspendu le mouvement las comme une
trace fantomatique pour un autre tour
s'interroger sur l'empreinte qu'on peut
laisser
[Musique]